hello hello and welcome to another
bitcoin protocol tutorial video
in this video we're going to be
discussing the privacy section of the
protocol paper
so a little more exciting than the
previous three sections
bitcoin and bitcoin protocol privacy is
kind of a hot topic issue because there
are also a lot of misconceptions
surrounding it and there's a lot of
uh opinions in some ways bitcoin is more
anonymous than your typical
online money methods but in other ways
it's actually more public
in the end it really comes down a lot to
user choice
and they can decide kind of where along
the spectrum they wish to be
now the government's gonna tell you that
this is a matter of national security
and terrorism and
people can't be private about their
finances but in reality though your
privacy
is your freedom and yeah criminals also
are gonna seek privacy but legit people
do too
and really it's your human right so how
does privacy and bitcoin work
um and is that even an issue so from the
paper
the traditional banking model achieves a
level of privacy by
limiting access to information to the
parties involved
and the trusted third party the
necessity to announce all transactions
publicly precludes this method
but privacy can still be maintained by
breaking the flow of information in
another place
by keeping public keys anonymous the
public
can see that someone is sending an
amount to someone else
but without information linking the
transactions to anyone this is similar
to the level
of information released by stock
exchanges where the time and size
of individual trades the tape so to
speak is made public but without telling
who the parties are
so here you can see the typical model uh
is that identities are tied
to transactions which go through the
trusted third party and then
end up at the counterparty and the
public is
basically not informed or better thought
of as separate from all of this
in the bitcoin protocol network um model
bitcoin protocol model identities are
the separate part and the transactions
basically go through the public in the
form of the ledger
so back to the paper as an additional
firewall a new key pair
should be used for each transaction to
keep them from being linked to a common
owner
some linking is still unavoidable with
multi-input transactions so kind of what
we were just discussing a moment ago
which necessary which necessarily reveal
that their inputs were owned by the same
owner
the risk is that if the owner of a key
is revealed
linking could reveal other transactions
that belonged to the same owner
now here's the important part where the
user gets the right to choose their
anonymity level in the case of a charity
for example they would likely if they're
legit
opt to possibly use the same public key
for all donations and expenditures
anyways this is so people could actually
see where the donation money was going
this is a business
or an organization that should be very
transparent
and this is a very easy way for people
to do that a corporation
with a lot of competition let's say
instead would probably choose to go the
secret route an anonymous route changing
their public key very often
so that it would be harder to track
where money is being spent
now obviously they would still be
required to report earnings um
you know the government for taxation
purposes and all of that so
that doesn't go away now this
optionality for anonymity is where the
debate is though i think it yields
the best of both worlds businesses and
organizations that should be transparent
now have an extremely simplistic way of
doing it business people in businesses
that have
a level of security invested in being
private
also have a simple way of doing so also
these options can even be married for a
perfect balance that
you can choose or your business can
choose so you can have your public funds
in one location the stuff you don't
really mind if people see
and then you can have some private
finances that you don't want the public
to be aware of how much
you have or what you spend your money on
now all of that
said when concerning you know this kind
of matters of national security and
terrorism kind of stuff
look tracking bitcoin payments is easier
than tracking most online payments and
it's
definitely easier than tracking cash
payments if
one really tries really hard um
they would relatively easily be able to
filter through all the payments and
eventually start linking accounts you
can make a tree
and if you have you know at least a few
accounts in mind
you can kind of start using process of
elimination and get rid of accounts and
you can start finding out
who exactly owns what true anonymity
is actually pretty hard to get away with
on this public
ledger so far some of the most anonymous
minded
people in bitcoin trying to evade law
enforcement
still have failed i don't think there's
any problem
with this added degree of privacy it's
simply just a new
model that's not necessarily more
private than the last and if anything i
would argue that this new model is
actually more public than the past
now i went ahead in this section and
gave my opinion so this floor is open of
course to anybody who wishes to disagree
with me and tell me i'm stupid or
whatever
if you have any questions or comments as
well feel free to leave them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions
and until next time